um it's dope too because like I do feel
like the last like
you know five or six years we've seen
like a dope uh you know we got guys like
pilo who are out here who are Filipino
obviously representing the bay but I
feel like uh artists who happen to be
Asian are like prospering there's a girl
named tweet that's popping right now
um for you how important is it to make
sure like you're representing for your
Homeland at the same time as being you
know representing Eminem and Dr Dre you
know what I mean it's me it's like
default like even when I try to spit it
just comes out naturally like it's
because
I feel like when it comes to riding
lines it just goes to show like from the
freestyle point it kind of also ask
yourself so that's all you're talking
about so where are you from and then you
say away from then it's just you already
represented without even knowing right
and then I just took that like into
perspective where I'm gonna take that
responsibility in throughout like going
forward what I've already said and you
know basically try to mature the sound
of like the music I've already created
and like you know still to the state
forward I still man how often do you go
back home or you know right now like
only
Fletcher not yet they're very expensive
not yet again but we did for a
homecoming tour like last last year
last yeah
last year yo I heard you can't do
anything out there that'll put you in
jail I just watched a Vice episode about
ah did you see that Vice episode man
don't be like getting to it but
if you know somebody you know somebody
don't worry if you come up I'm not
coming to the Philippines and smoking
weed see most times when I go to a
different country I'll bring weed with
me because I'll be like there I heard
they don't [__] around I heard that
President don't play around there used
to it'd be and then jails look very
populated
they look crazy yeah
yo we were talking a little bit off
camera about uh the most I would say
like legendary Filipino Cuisine for
people who don't like eat normal [__]
you know they see like tick tocks of was
it balut and it's uh it's it's I want to
try it
I don't want to try it I feel like I
kind of have to try it it's like a half
is it a chicken
is it a duck yep oh so it's a half like
it's almost like a duck embryo that's
like half developed right yeah have you
had it I had it like two times in my
life how is it
um it's an acquired taste you put hot
sauce on it
or any sort of sauce you just eat it the
way it is I would just put soy sauce soy
sauce okay let's try it
I gotta give it a shot man is it crunchy
um depends on what you would say crunchy
people I'm making a tick tock out of it
for sure
for sure making a tick tock out of it
let's go I can't wait to watch them
maybe we'll do it together okay all
right yeah you'll serve it up I'll eat
it and then you know everybody can make
fun of me for
for uh what I'm sure will be a
interesting
reaction oh yeah yeah I'm putting cable
I love some balloon